so homework 2 is out now I recognize
that there's a really broad spectrum of
background in terms of whether people
have seen deep learning or not before or
taking a class or used it extensively
just a quick hambo who which if you have
used tensorflow or pie charts before a
number of you but not everybody so what
we're gonna be doing this week in
sessions is we're gonna be having some
more background on deep learning you're
not expected to become or to be a deep
learning expert to be in this class but
we you will need to have some basic
skills in order to do homework 2 I'm
gonna be able to use function
approximation with a deep neural network
so I encourage you to go to session this
week if you don't have a background on
that we're gonna today cover a little
bit on deep learning but very very small
amount and focus more on deep
reinforcement learning but these
sessions will be a good chance to catch
up on that material we're also going to
be reaching releasing by the end of
tomorrow what the default project will
be for this class and you guys will get
to pick whether or not you want to do
your own construction project or the
default project and those proposals will
be due fairly soon in a little over a
week there any other questions that
people have right now yes the question
of if the assignment is limited to
tensorflow
I'm pretty sure that everything relies
that you're using tensorflow
so yeah just feel free to reach out on
Piazza to double-check that but I'm
pretty sure any all of our other graders
just set up for tensorflow so for this
one even if you use by torch normally
please use tensor glue all of you guys
also should have access to the azure
credit if you have any questions about
getting set up with that feel free to
use the Piazza Piazza channel we also
released a tutorial for how to just sort
of set up your machine last week so if
you're having any questions with that
that's a great place to get started you
look at the tutorial you can look at the
video or you can reach out to us on
Piazza any other questions all right so
we're going to go ahead and get started
I'm what we're gonna be covering today
is sort of a very brief overview about
deep learning as well as deep key
learning so in terms of were on the
class we've been
discussing how to learn to make
decisions from the world when we don't
know the dynamics model of the reward
model in advance and last week we were
discussing value function approximation
particularly linear value function
approximation and today we're going to
start to talk about other forms of value
function approximation in particular
using deep neural networks so why do we
want to do this at all well the reasons
we wanted to start thinking about using
function approximate errs is that if we
want to be able to use reinforcement
learning to tackle really complex hairy
problems we need to be able to deal with
the fact that often we're gonna have
very high dimensional input signals or
observations so we want to be able to
deal with sort of pixel input like
images or we want to be able to deal
with really complex information about
customers or patients or students where
we might have enormous state and our
action spaces I'll note today that we're
mostly not going to talk so much about
enormous action spaces but we are going
to think a lot about really large state
spaces and so when we started talking
about those I was arguing that we either
need representations of models those
mean the sort of the dynamics or the
reward models T or R or R state action
values Q or V or our policies that can
generalize across States and our actions
with the idea being that we may in fact
never encounter the exact same state
again you might never see the exact same
image of the world again but we want to
be able to generalize from our past
experience and so we thought about
instead of having a table to represent
our value functions we were going to use
this generic function approximator where
we have a W now which are some
parameters and when we thought about
doing this we said what we're gonna
focus on is we're gonna focus on
function approximations that are
differentiable and the nice thing about
differentiable about representations is
that we can use our data we can estimate
our parameters and then we can take use
gradient descent to try to fit our
function to try to write that and to
write or represent our q function or a
value function so i mentioned last time
but most the time we're gonna think
about trying to quantify the fit of our
function compared to the true value as a
mean squared error so we can define our
loss J and we can use gradient descent
on that to try to find
parameters W that optimize and just as a
reminder stochastic gradient descent was
useful because when we could just slowly
update our parameters as we get more
information and that information now
could be in the form of episodes or it
could be individual tuples when I say a
tuple I generally mean a state action
reward next state couple and the nice
thing is that the expected stochastic
gradient descent is the same as the full
gradient update so just to remind
ourselves last time we were talking
about linear value function approximator
x' and that meant that what we're gonna
do is are gonna have a whole bunch of
features to describe our world as so you
know these features we would input our
state state as the real state of the
world and we would output our features
and so this could be things like our
laser rangefinder for our robot which
told us how far away the walls were in
all 180 degree directions we talked
about the fact that that was an alias
version of the world because multiple
hallways might look identical so our
value function now is a dot product
between those features that we've got
out about the world with the weights our
objective function is again the mean
squared error and then we could do this
same weight update and the key hard
thing was that we don't know what this
is so this is the true value of a policy
and the problem is we don't know what
the true value of a policy is otherwise
we wouldn't have to be doing all of this
learning and so we needed to have
different ways to approximate it and so
the two ways we talked about last time
was inspired by our work on Monte Carlo
or on TD learning is we could either
plug in the return from a full episode
this is the sum of rewards or we could
put in a bootstrapped return so now
we're doing bootstrapping
get the reward the next state and the
value of our next state and in this case
we're using linear value function
approximator x' for everything which
gave us a really simple form of what the
derivative is of this function with
respect to W basically it's just our
features x essentially this prediction
error so people sometimes call this is
the prediction error because it's the
difference between the value or right
now we're using GT as the true value of
course in reality it's just a sample of
the value but it's the difference
between the true value and our estimated
value who I'm going to shrink that
difference so in this case I've written
these equations all for linear value
function approximation but there are
some limitations to using linear value
function approximation even though those
has been probably the most well studied
so if you have the right set of features
and historically there was a lot of work
I'm figuring out what those right set of
features are they often work really well
and in fact when we get into I think I
mentioned briefly before when we start
to talk about deep neural networks you
can think of a deep neural network is
just a really complicated way to get out
features plus the last layer being a
linear combination of those features but
most the time when we're talking about
deep RL with deep neural network to
represent the key function that's the
type of representation we'll be looking
at so linear value function is often
really works very well if you're the
right set of features but it's this
challenge of what is the right set of
features and there are all sorts of
implications about whether or not we're
even going to be able to write down the
true value function using our set of
features and how easy is it for us to
converge to that so one alternative that
we didn't talk so much about last time
is to use sort of a really really rich
function approximate our class where we
don't have to have a direct
representation of the features and some
of those are kernel based approaches
has anybody seen like kernel based
approaches before or like k nearest
neighbor type or type approaches
probably taking machine learning you've
heard of K nearest neighbors those are
these nonparametric approaches where
your representation size tends to grow
with a number of data points and the
they can be really nice and they have
some actually
really nice convergence properties for
reinforcement learning the problem is
that the number of data points you need
tends to scale with the dimension so if
you have let's say those 180 features
the number of points you need to tile
that hundred and eighty degrees space
generally scales exponentially with the
dimension so that's not so appealing
both in terms of computational
complexity memory requirements and
sample complexity so that these actually
have a lot stronger convergence results
compared to linear value function
approximate errs but they haven't been
used for in a very widespread way yeah I
mean everyone just named Chris please
just help me yeah yeah question was why
does the exponential behavior happen and
a lot of these sort of kernel based
approximator Zoar nonparametric the
intuition is that if you want to have
sort of an accurate representation of
your value function and you're
representing it by say local points
around it for example like with the K
nearest neighbors approach then the
number of points you need to have
everything be close like in an epsilon
ball scales with the the dimensionality
so basically you're just creating the
space so if you think of if you think of
sort of if you want to have any point on
this line be close then you could put a
point here and a point here in order to
have everything be sort of epsilon close
for all points on that line to have a
neighbor that's within epsilon distance
if you want to have it in a square
you're gonna need four points so that
everything can be somewhat close to one
of the points and generally the number
of points you need is gonna scale
exponentially with the dimension but
they are really nice because they can be
guaranteed to be averages which we
talked about really briefly last time
that use a linear value function
approximator
when you do a build went back up it's
not necessarily a contraction operator
anymore which is why you can sometimes
blow up as you know more more backups
the really cool thing about apertures is
sort of by their name when you use this
type of approximation you don't they're
guaranteed B to be a non expansion which
means that when you
buying them with the bellman back up
scarran teeth still be a contraction
really cool so that means these sort of
approximate errs are guaranteed to
converge compared to a lot of other ones
all right but they're talking the scale
very well and in practice you don't tend
to see them though there's some really
cool work by my colleague finale joshi
fellows over at Harvard who's thinking
about using these for things like
healthcare applications and how do you
sort of generalize from related patients
so they can be useful but generally
don't scale so well so what we're gonna
talk about today is thinking about deep
neural networks which also have very
flexible representations but we hope
we're gonna scale a lot better now a
general we're gonna have almost no
theoretical guarantees for the rest of
today I and but in practice they often
work really really well so they've
become an incredibly useful tool and
reinforcement learning and everywhere
else really in terms of machine learning
so what do we mean by deep neural
networks well number of you guys are
experts but what it generally means in
this case is we're just going to think
of making a function approximator which
is a composition of a number of
functions so we're gonna have our input
X and I'm gonna feed it into some
function which is going to take in some
wheats so in general of these things can
be vectors so you gotta take in some
weights and combine them with your X and
then you're gonna push them into some
function and then you're gonna output
something which is probably going to be
also a vector and then you can push that
into another function and throw in some
more weights we're gonna do that a whole
bunch of times
and then at the very end of that we're
going to output some Y which you can
think of as being like our Q and then we
can output that to some loss function J
so what does that mean here it means
that Y is equal to H and of H n minus 1
of tot of each one of X and I haven't
written
weights that are going in there but
there's a whole bunch of weights too and
then this is our last one should like
before and this you can think of as like
our cue for example but these are
capital letters and supervised learning
like predicting whether or not something
is a cat or not or you know an image of
a particular object or for regression
and so why do we want to do this well
first of all it should be clear that as
you compose lots of functions you could
represent really complicated functions
by you know adding and subtracting and
taking polynomials I'm all sorts of
things you could do by just composing
functions together that this could be a
really powerful space of functions you
could represent but the nice reason to
write it down like this is that you can
do the chain rule to try to do
stochastic gradient descent so how does
this work well that means that we can
write down that DJ so we really want you
know DJ with respect to all these
different parameters and so what we can
write down here is we can write down DJ
of H N and D H band of d WN and we can
do that do this kind of everywhere so DJ
of H to D H of H to DHT or DW so you can
use the chain rule to propagate all of
this the the gradient of your loss
function would speak to W all the way
back down all of these different
compositions by writing out the chain
rule and so that's night be nice because
it means that you can take your output
signal and then propagate that back in
terms of updating all of your weights
now I'm gonna date myself so when I
first learned about deep neural networks
you had to do this by hand and so as you
might imagine this was a less popular
assignment and and you it's called back
propagation so you can derive this by
hand and I'll talk in a second about
what these type of functions are you
know you need differentiable functions
for H but I think one of the major major
innovations that's happened over there
you know roughly what like the last five
to eight years is that there's auto
differentiation so that now you don't
have to drive all of these gradients by
hand instead you can just write down
your network parameter
and then your network of Prayer which
includes a bunch of parameters and then
you have software like tensorflow to do
all of the differentiation for you so I
think these sort of tools have made it
much much more practical for people lots
and lots of people to use deep neural
networks because you don't you can have
very very complicated networks with very
very large amount of layers and there's
no sort of hand writing down with what
the gradients are so what are these H
functions generally they combine both
linear and nonlinear transformations
basically they just they have to be
differentiable so you know these these H
need to be differentiable if we're gonna
use gradient descent does it fit them
and so the common choices are either
linear so you can think of HN is equal
to W HN minus 1 or nonlinear where we
can think of HN is equal to some
function HN minus 1 and if it's
nonlinear we often call this an
activation function due to time I'm not
going to talk in class much about the
connections with neural networks which
is what inside of our brain which is
what's inspiring these sort of
artificial neural networks but inside of
the brain people think of there as being
these sort of nonlinear activation
functions where if the signal passes a
certain threshold then for example a
neuron would fire and so these sort of
nonlinear activation functions can be
things like sigmoid functions or raloo
really was particularly popular right
now so you can choose different
combinations of linear functions or
nonlinear functions and as usual we need
a loss function at the end typically we
use mean squared error you could also
use log likelihood but we need something
that then we can differentiate how close
we are at achieving that target in order
to update our weights yeah name first
so this Brailler function is not
differentiable dirt
it is variable like you can you can you
can take a different and it's ended up
being a lot more popular than sigmoid
recently though I feel like it's flat
well if it's flat that's theorem so that
ends up just great it's just so question
is about how for real oh there's a lot
of it where it's flat and so if your
gradient 0 then your gradients can
vanish there and in in general actually
we're not gonna talk about this at all
in class but there's certainly a problem
as you start having very very deep
neural networks but because of some of
these functions you can sometimes end up
sort of having almost no signal going
back to the earlier layers but I'm not
going to talk about any of that will
target will talk to some about that in
sessions and they're good to be aware of
and we're also happy to give other
pointers but yeah if it's flat it's ok
you can still just have a 0 okay all
right so why do we want to do this well
it's nice we can use this sort of like
much more complicated representation
another thing is that if you have at
least one hidden layer if you have a
sufficient number of nodes it was you
can think of as if you're not familiar
with this is basically just sort of a
sufficiently complicated set of a
combination of features and functions
this is a universal function
approximator which means that you can
represent any function with the deep
neural network so that's really nice
we're not gonna have any capacity
problems if we use a sufficiently
expressive function approximator and
that's important because if you think
about what we're doing with linear value
function approximator x' it was clearly
the case sometimes that you might have
two limited features and you just
wouldn't be able to express the true
value function for some states and what
the universal function approximator
property is stating is that that will
not occur for deep neural network if it
is sufficiently rich now of course you
could always think of doing a linear
value function approximator with very
very rich features and then that becomes
equivalent so given that you know what's
another benefit another benefit is that
potentially you can you
exponentially less nodes or parameters
compared to using a shallow net which
means not as many of those compositions
to represent the same function that's
pretty elegant and I'm happy to talk
about that offline or we can talk about
on Piazza and then the final thing is
that you can learn the parameters using
stochastic gradient descent alright so
that's pretty much that's you know D bro
networks in like five seconds we're now
going to talk a little bit about
convolutional neural networks and again
this is all going to be a pretty light
introduction because you're not going to
need to know the details the nerd to do
the homework except for mostly the
effective understanding that these are
sort of very expressive function
approximate ease so why do we care about
convolutional neural networks and well
they're used very extensively in
computer vision and if we're interested
in having robots and other sorts of
agents that can interact in the real
world one of our primary sensory
modalities is vision and it's very
likely that we're going to want to be
able to use similar sorts of input on
our robots and artificial agents so if
you think about this think about there
being an image of this case of Einstein
and there's a whole bunch of different
pixels on Einstein and this picture of
Einstein and let's say it's a thousand
by a thousand so it's a thousand by a
thousand you know x and y and so we have
ten to the six pixels so the standard
often called feed-forward deep neural
network you would have all of those
pixels and then they would be going as
input to another layer and you might
want to have a bunch of different nodes
that are taking input from all of those
and so you can get a huge number of
weights so you might have 10 to the 6
weights 4 that's the often we think
about through I know I haven't given you
enough details about this but often we
think of there as being sort of this
deep neural network where we have many
functions in parallel so it's not just
like a single one but we might have X
going into F h1 h2 h3 h4 then all of
those would then be going in some
complicated way to some other functions
so you can have lots of sort of
functions being computed in parallel
and so you can imagine your image goes
and you've got one function that
computes some aspects of the image and
another function that computes some
other aspect of the image and then
you're going to combat combine those and
all sorts of complicated ways so what
this is saying is well for that very
first one there's maybe going to be you
know a whole bunch of n different
functions for computing of the image
there'd be 10 to the 6 parameters here
so if we have just weights times X then
that would be 10 to the 6 parameters to
take in all of that X but the lot and
then if we want to do this for doing
different types of weights all in
parallel then that's going to be a very
very large number of parameters and we
do have a lot of data off it now but
that's still an enormous number of
parameters to to represent and it also
sort of misses some of the point of what
we often think about with vision so if
we think about doing this many times and
having lots of hidden units we can get a
really an enormous number of parameters
so to avoid sort of this space-time
complexity and the fact that we're sort
of ignoring the structure of images
convolutional neural networks try to
have a particular form of deep neural
network it tries to think about the
properties of images so in particular
images often have structure and the way
that our brain promises images also has
structure and the sort of distinctive
features and space and frequency so when
you have a convolutional neural network
we think of there being particular types
of operators and so operators again here
are like our functions H 1 and H n which
I said before it could either be linear
or nonlinear an accomplishable neural
network we're not particular structures
for those for those functions that try
to sort of think about the properties
that we might want to be extracting from
images and kind of the key aspects here
is that we're going to do a lot of
weight sharing to do parameter reduction
so instead of saying I'm going to have
totally different parameters each taking
in all of the pixels I'm going to end up
having sort of local parameters that are
identical and then I apply them to
different parts of the image to try to
extract for example features because
ultimately the point of doing this is
going to be try to extracting features
that we think are going to be useful for
either predicting things
whether or not you know a faces in an
image or that are gonna help us in terms
of understanding what the cue function
should be so the key idea one of the key
ideas is to say that we're gonna have a
filter or a receptive field which is
that we're gonna have some hidden unit
so that's gonna be a function that's
applied to some previous input at the
beginning that's just going to be a
subset of our image and instead of
taking in the whole image we're just
gonna take in part so we're just gonna
take in a patch so now we're gonna take
the upper corner we're gonna take the
middle so it's like we're just going to
try to compute some properties of a
particular patch of the image and so
then we can imagine taking it's often
called a filter that little those set of
weights that were applied to that patch
and we could do that all over the image
and we often call the there's a stride
which means sort of how much you move
that little patch at each time point
there's also this thing called zero
padding which is how many errors to add
on each input layer and this determines
sort of help helps determine what your
output is so in this case if you have an
input of 28 by 28 then you have a little
5x5 patch that you're gonna slide over
the entire image then you're gonna end
up with a 24 by 24 and layer next
because basically you just take this and
then you move it over a little bit you
move it over and each of those times
you're going to take those 25 so this is
5 by 5 so you gonna have 25 input X's
and you're gonna dot product them with
some weights and that's gonna give you
an output so here in this case that
means we're gonna need 25 weeks so one
thing is instead of having our full x
input we're just going to take in we're
going to direct different parts of the X
input to different neurons which you can
think of is just different functions but
the other nice idea here is that we're
going to have the same weights for
everything so when we took those weights
we're gonna have sort of you can think
of them as trying to extract a feature
from that sub patch of the image for
example whether or not there's an edge
so you could imagine I'm trying to
detect whether or not there's something
that looks like a horizontal edge in
that part of the image and I
I too and that is determined by the late
so I'm specifying and I just move that
over my entire image to see whether or
not it's present so now the weights are
identical and you're just moving them
over the entire image so instead of
having you know ten to the six weights
am I only having twenty-five weights and
I'm applying those to the same just
applying them to lots of different parts
of the image okay so this is sort of
what that would look like you sort of
have this inputs you go to the hidden
layer and yeah you're sort of also down
sampling the image why would you want to
do this well we think that often the
brain is doing this it's trying to pick
up different sort of features in fact a
lot of computer vision before deep
learning was trying to construct these
special sorts of features things like
sift features or other features or that
we think capture sort of important
properties of the image that also may be
invariant to things like translation
because we also think that you know
whether I'm looking at the world like
this or I move my head slightly that the
features that I see are often going to
be identical whether I move to the left
or right a little bit there are
particular salient aspects of the world
that are going to be relevant for
detecting whether or not there's a face
and relevant for deciding my value
function so we want to sort of extract
features that we think are gonna
represent this sort of translation
invariance so this means also that
rather than just computing that you can
do this you use the same weights all the
way across the feature all across the
image and then you can do this for
multiple different types of features so
there's a really nice discussion of this
that goes into more depth from 2:31 and
which some of you guys might have taken
and there's a nice animation where they
show okay imagine you have your input
can think of this is an image and then
you could apply these different filters
on top of it but you can think of as
trying to detect different features and
then you move them around your image and
see whether or not that feature is
present anywhere so you can do that with
multiple different types of filters you
could think of this as trying to look
for whether something's like that or
some things you know horizontal or
vertical different types of edges and
these give you different features
essentially that have been extracted the
other really important thing in cnn's is
what are known as pooling layers they're
often used as a way to sort of down
sample the image so you can do things
like max bullying to detect whether or
not a particular feature is present or
take averages or other ways to kind of
just down and compress the the
information that you got it in just
remember in this case and in many cases
we're going to start with a really high
dimensional input like X might be an
image an output a scaler like you know
the Q value so we're somehow going to
have to go for a really high dimensional
input and kind of average and slow down
until we can get to a low dimensional
output so the final layer is typically
fully connected so we can again think
about all of these previous processes is
essentially computing some new feature
representation so essentially from here
to here we're kind of computing this new
feature representation of the image and
the very end we can take some fully
connected layer we're like doing linear
regression and use that to output
predictions or scalars again I know
either for some of you guys this is sort
of a quick shallow refresher for others
of you this is clearly not in this is
would be a whirlwind introduction but we
won't be requiring you to know a lot of
these details and again just go to
session if you have some questions and
feel free to reach out to us okay so
these type of representations both deep
neural networks and convolutional neural
networks are both used extensively and
deep reinforcement learning so it was
around in 2014 where I the workshop
where David silver started talking about
how we could use these type of
approximations for Atari so why was this
surprising I just sort of wanna bring
back so in around 1994 approximately
1994 we had TV backgammon which used
deep neural networks well they used know
how that works I think there was someone
too deep and they got like a world-class
backgammon player out of that so that
was pretty early on and then we had the
results that were kind of happening
around like 1995 - maybe them in 1998
which said that function approximation
plus off line off policy control
Plus bootstrapping can be bad you can
fail to converge we talked about this a
little last time that in general as soon
as we start doing this function
approximation even the linear function
approximator that when you're combining
off policy control bootstrapping which
means we're doing like TD learning or Q
learning and a function approximator
then you can start to have this
challenging triad which often means that
we're not guaranteed to converge and
even we're guaranteed to converge the
solution may not be a good one so sort
of there was this early encouraging
success and then there were these
results in sort of the middle of the 90s
that were trying to better understand
this that indicated that things could be
very bad and there was sort of in
addition to the theoretical results
there was were these simple test cases
that it you know these simple cases that
went wrong so it wasn't just sort of in
principle this could happen but there
were cases which failed and so I think
for a long time after that the the
community was sort of backed away from
deep neural networks for a while people
were quite cautious about using them
because there were clearly even simple
cases where things started to go really
badly with function approximation and
theoretically people could prove that it
could go badly and so there's there less
attention to it for quite a while and
then there was the rise of deep neural
networks and sort of you know the the
mid 2000s like so now so deep neural
networks became huge and there was
clearly huge success in them for things
like vision and other areas there's a
whole bunch of data there's a whole
bunch of compute they were getting
really extraordinary results and so then
perhaps it was natural that like around
in like 2014 mind do you mind combine
them and had some really amazing
successes for the Atari and so I think
it sort of really changed the story of
how people are perceiving using these
sort of complicated function
approximation
mater's and RL and that yes it can fail
to converge yes things can go really
badly and they do go really badly
sometimes in practice but it is also
possible often that despite that you
know the fact that we don't always fully
understand
they always work that often in practice
we can still get pretty good policies
out now we often don't know if they're
optimal often we know they're not
optimal because we know that people can
play better but that doesn't mean that
they might not be pretty good and so we
sort of saw this resurgence of interest
in into deep reinforcement learning yeah
I guess is there anything from your
perspective that the deep learning had
solved the problems that they had come
up with in the mid 90s or is it just
that kind of through increases in
computational power and the ability to
gather a lot of data that when it failed
it kind of doesn't matter and we can try
some different like we you know try it
again kind of reput it together and then
just keep trying until it works I guess
my question is have we actually overcome
any of the problems that arose in the
late 90s or is it just that we're just
kind of powering through question as you
know helping sort of fundamentally
resolve some of the issues of the late
90s or are we kind of brute-forcing it
um I think that some of the issues that
were coming up in 1995 through 1988 in
terms of convergence there are some
algorithms now that are more true
stochastic gradient algorithms that are
covered in chapter 11 so that I are
guaranteed to converge they may not be
guaranteed to converge the optimal
policy so there's still a lot of there's
still a ton of work I think to be done
to understand function approximated off
policy control and bootstrapping I think
there's also a couple algorithmic ideas
that we're gonna see later in this
lecture that help the performance kind
of avoid some of those convergence
problems so I think people knew about
this when they started going into 2013
2014 and so they tried to think about
well when might this issue happen and
how could we avoid some of that stuff
like what's causing that and so at least
algorithmically can we try to make
things people often talk about stability
so can we try to make sure that the deep
neural network doesn't seem to start
having weights that are going off
towards infinity and at least
empirically have sort of more stable
performance yes did you did you avoid
the problems or they did be tried by
having on policy control I just don't
know I thought me for something where
wasn't the case that in fact and usual
experiment they updated the performance
to measure the optimal seesaw reveal pie
or problem boy cute this is whether or
not in the sort of if I should currently
in the Atari case like you know where
they change the things to be more on
policy or which we know can be much more
stable and they are doing deep learning
in this case deep Q learning and so it
can still be very unstable but they're
gonna do something about how they do the
frequency of updates to the networks to
try to make it more stable and your
great questions let me we'll see how it
works ok cool so well we'll see an
example for breakout shortly of what
they did so again right now we're going
to be talking about using deep neural
networks to represent the value function
talk about using deep neural networks to
represent the policy pretty shortly
sweet so what are we gonna do we're
gonna again have our weights we're gonna
have our same approximate errs now we're
going to be using deep neural networks
and in this case again just to be clear
we're gonna be using a cue function
because we're gonna want to be able to
be doing control so we're gonna be doing
control in this case and so we're gonna
need to be learning the values of the
actions just to be clear here an Atari
it generally doesn't have a really high
dimensional action space it's discrete
it's normally somewhere between like 4
to 18 depends on the game so it's fairly
low dementia fairly it's discrete and
fairly small so though the state space
is enormous because it's pixels it's
images I the action space is pretty
smoky ok so just as a reminder for
q-learning what we saw is q-learning
looks like this for our weights we have
to have the derivative of our function
this is not necessarily going to be
linear anymore
but the way we updated our weights was
we did this TD back up where we have
this target but we're now going to be
taking them max over a over our next
state in our action and our weights now
notice in this equation all the W's you
see are identical on the right hand side
so we're using the same weights to
represent our current value now we're
using our same weights to plug in and
get an estimate of our future value as
well as in our derivative and one thing
we're gonna see is a
an alternative to that okay so their
idea was we'd really like to be able to
use this type of function approximator
at these deep function approximator is
to do Atari
they picked Atari in part well I think
at least Jamieson I think he was David
both had sort of a joint startup on
video games a long time ago I think it
was before David went back to grad
school if I remember correctly
so they're both interests in this it's
clearly games are often hard for people
to learn I'm so it's a nice sort of
demonstration of intellect and they
thought well we can get access to this
and there was a paper published
forgetting man maybe 2011-2013 talking
about Atari games and emulators as being
sort of interesting challenge for RL so
what happens in this case well the state
is just going to be the full image the
action is going to be the equivalent of
actions of what you could normally do in
the game this is normally somewhere
between 4 to 18 approximately 4 to 18
actions and the reward can be well
really whatever you want but you can use
the score or some other aspect I as
proxy reward general are going to think
about score so what's going to happen
well they're going to use a particular
input state we've talked before about
whether or not a representation is
Markov in these games you typically need
to have velocity so because you need
velocity you need more than just the
current image so what they chose to do
is you need to use for previous frames
so this will least allows you to catch
for velocity in position I've sort of
the balls and things like that it's not
always sufficient can anybody think of
an example where maybe an Atari game I
don't know how many people played Atari
um I that might not be sufficient where
you know for the last four images still
might not be sufficient or the type of
game where it might not be sufficient
my crisps exactly right so like things
like Montezuma's Revenge things where
you often have to get like a key and
then you have to grab that key and then
maybe it's visible on screen movies and
but maybe it's stored in inventory
somewhere so you have to sort of
remember that you have it in order to
make the right decision much later or
there might be some information you've
seen early on so there are a lot of
games a lot of tasks where the even the
last four frames will not give me the
information you need but it's not a bad
approximation it's much easier than
representing the entire history so they
started with that a so here in this case
there's 18 joystick button positions may
or may not need to use all of them in a
particular game and the reward can be
the change in score now notice that that
can be very helpful or may not be it
depends on the game so in some games
that takes you a really really long time
to get to anywhere where your score can
possibly change so in that case you
might have a really sparse reward in
other cases you're going to reward a lot
and so that's going to be much easier to
learn what to do one of the important
things that they did in their paper this
is a nature paper from 2015 is they use
the same architecture and hyper
parameters across all games now just to
be clear they're gonna then you learn
different cue functions and different
policies for each game but their point
was that they didn't have to use totally
different architectures and do totally
different hyper parameter tuning for
every single game separately in order to
get it to work it really was that the
sort of general architecture and setup
was sufficient for them to be able to
learn to make good decisions for all of
the games I think it was another nice
contribution to this paper is to say
well we're gonna try to get sort of a
general algorithm and setup that is
gonna go much beyond the sort of normal
three examples that we see and
reinforcement learning papers just try
gonna try to do well in all 50 games
again each agent is going to learn from
scratch in each of the 50 games but it's
going to do so with the same basic
parameters same type of Crowder's and
same neural network it's the same
function approximator all right and the
nice thing is that I think this is
actually required by nature they release
the source code as well so you can play
around with this so how did they do it
well they're gonna do value function
approximator so they're they're
representing the cue function they're
going to minimize the mean squared lost
by stochastic gradient descent
but we know that this can diverge with
value function approximator x' and what
are two of the problems for this well
one is that very the sort of the
correlation between samples which means
that if you have s a are s prime a prime
R prime it's double Prime if you think
about what the value function or the
return is for s and the value function
and the return for s prime are they
independent no right in fact like you
expect them to be highly correlated
there probably you know I mean it
depends on the probability of s prime if
this is a deterministic system the only
difference between the will be R so so
these are highly correlated these are
not iid samples when we're doing updates
there's a lot of correlations and also
this issue with non stationary targets
what does that mean it means that when
you're trying to do your supervised
learning and train your value function
predictor it's not like you always have
the same V PI Oracle that's telling you
what the true value is that's changing
over time because you're doing Q
learning to try to estimate what that is
and your policy is changing and so it's
huge amounts of non stationarity so you
don't have a stationary target when
you're even just trying to fit your
function because it could be constantly
changing each step so you change your
pilot you change your weights then you
change your policy and then now you're
gonna change your weights again and so
perhaps not surprising that things might
be very hard in terms of convergence so
the way that through DQ n deep Q
learning addresses these is by
experience replay and fix q targets
experience replay probably umber if you
guys have heard about this if you
learned about DQ n before is we're just
going to store old data we've talked
about a little bit before how like TD
learning in their standard approach just
uses a data point now what I mean by
data point here is really one of these s
AR s prime tuples in the simplest way of
TD learning or key learning use that
once and you throw it away that's great
for data storage it's not so good for
performance so the idea is that we're
just going to store this we're going to
keep around some finite buffer of prior
experience and we're gonna really redo Q
learning updates let's just remember Q
learning update here would be looking
like this
we would update our weights that's
considered one update take a tuple and
update the weight it's like one
stochastic gradient descent update and
so you can just sample from your
experience replay with your replay
buffer you compute the target value
given your current cue function and then
you do stochastic gradient descent now
notice here because your cue function
will be changing over time
each time you do your update of a budget
of the same couple you might have a
different target value because your cue
function has changed for that point this
is nice because basically it means that
you reuse your data instead of just
using each data point once you can reuse
it and that can be helpful and what
we'll look at that more in a minute so
even though we're treating the target is
a scalar the weights will get update on
the next round which means our target
value changes and so you can sort of
propagate that's information and
essentially the main idea is just that
we're going to use data more than once
and that's often very helpful yes and
numeracy my question is is this
privileged to keeping more frames in our
representation is this is this
equivalent to keep you more frames in
our representation it's not that's a
really interesting question more frames
would be like keeping a more complicated
state representation but you could still
just use a state action award next state
tuple once and throw that data way this
is like saying that periodically I like
let's say I've went s1 a 1 R 1 s 2 and
then I keep going on and now I'm at like
s 3 a 3 R 3 S 4 so that's really where
I'm in the world I'm now in state 4 it's
like I suddenly pretend oh wait I'm
gonna pretend that I'm back in s1 took a
1 got R 1 I went to s 2 and I'm going to
update my weights again and the reason
that that update will be different than
before is because I've now updated using
my second update of my third update so
my Q function in general will be
different than before so it will cause a
different weight update so even though
it's the same data point as before it's
going to cause a different weight update
and in general one thing we talked about
a long time ago is that if you do TD
learning to convergence which means that
you go over your data like
an infinite amount of time at least in
the tabular case that is equivalent to
if you learned an MDP model you learn
the transition dynamics in the reward
model and you just did MDP planning with
that
that's what TD learning converges to I
said if you sort of repeatedly go
through your data an infinite amount of
time
Benchley it'll converge to as if you
would learn to model and dynamic small
in reward model and then did planning
for that which is pretty cool so this is
getting us closer to that but we don't
want to do that all the time because
there's a computation trade-off and
particularly here because we're in games
there's a direct trade off between
computation and getting more experience
it's actually a really interesting
trade-off because in these cases it's
sort of like should you think more and
planned use your old data or should you
just gather more experience but we can
talk more about that later yeah question
and main press please so if the
experience replay buffer has like a
fixed size just for like clarification
of understanding are those samples like
replaced by new samples after finishing
out of time or is there like a specific
way to choose what samples the storing
the buffer great question which is okay
this is presumably gonna be a fixed size
buffer and if it is a fixed size buffer
how do you pick what's in it and there's
recent and and how do you get things out
of how do you remove items from it it's
a really interesting question different
people do different things normally it's
often the most recent buffer can be for
example the last one million samples
which gives you a highlight of how many
samples we're going to be talking about
but you can make different choices and
there's interesting questions of what
things you should kick out it also
depends if your problem is really non
stationary or not and what I mean there
is like the real world is not stationary
like your customer base is changing yeah
try to strike the right balance between
continuing to experience like new data
points versus reapplying it do we do
something similar to an exploitation
versus exploration and essentially like
with random probability just decide to
replay decisions about how would we
choose between like what you know
getting you data and how much to replay
etc and could we do that sort of as an
exploration exploitation trade-off I
think this is generally under studied
there's a lots of different heuristics
people use often people have some sort
of a fixed ratio of how much they're
updating base
the experience we played versus getting
put in new samples into there so
generally right now is sort of your
state trade off could certainly imagine
trying to optimally figure this out but
that also requires computation and this
gets us into the really interesting
question of meta computation and
metacognition
of you know your agent thinking about
how to prioritize its own computation
which is a super cool problem which is
what we solve all the time okay so the
second thing that dqn does is it first
half it first keeps around this old data
the second thing that it does is it has
fixed cue targets so what does that mean
so to improve stability and what we mean
by stability here is that we don't want
our weights to explode and go to
infinity which we saw could happen in
linear value function we're gonna fix
the target weights that are used in the
target calculation for multiple updates
so remember here what I mean by the
target calculation here is that reward
plus gamma V of S prime so this itself
is a function of W and we're going to
fix the W we use in that value of s
prime for several rounds so instead of
always update taking whatever the most
recent one is we're just gonna fix it
for a while and that's basically like
making this more stable because this in
general is an approximation of the
Oracle of V star so you'd really like it
Oracle to just give this to you every
time you reach you know an S Prime or
you take an action getting it go to s
prime you'd like an Oracle to give you
what the true value is you don't have
that and it could change on every single
step because you could be updating the
weights what this is saying is don't do
that keep the weights fixed that used
compute PS prime for a little while
maybe for 10 steps maybe for a hundred
steps and that just makes the target the
sort of the thing that you're trying to
minimize your loss with respect to more
stable so we're gonna have we saw our
single network but we're just going to
maintain two different sets of weights
for that Network one is gonna be this
weights - you call it - because well
there might be other conventions but in
particular it's the older set of weights
so the ones we're not updating right now
and those are the ones that we're using
in this target calculation
so those are the ones we're gonna use
when we want to figure out the value of
s Prime and then we have some other W
which is what we're using to update and
so when we compute our target value we
again can example an experience tuple
from the data set from our experience
replay buffer compute the target value
using our W - and then we use stochastic
gradient descent update the network
weights so this is used with - this is
used with the current one I guess
super psych intuitively why this is felt
and it's like why does it make it more
stable and like secondly like are there
any other ability to - one is
intuitively why does this help M which
is a great question and second of all
beyond the stability is there any other
benefits so intuitively why does this
help in terms of stability in terms of
stability it helps because you're
basically reducing the noise in your
target if you think back to a Monte
Carlo and there instead of using this
target like this bootstrap target we
were using GT so in Monte Carlo we use
GT and I told you the nice thing about
that was that it was an unbiased
estimator of the PI but the downside was
that it was high variance just summing
up the rewards till the end of the
episode and so things are high variance
when you're trying to regress on them
it's gonna be more noisy and you could
be asked irradiance imagine that we do
something take the extreme of this if we
want to be for stability you could
always make your target equal to a
constant could always make it equal to
zero for example and if you kept your
target fixed forever you would learn the
weights that that minimize the error to
a constant function and that would then
be stable because you always have a the
same target value they are always trying
to predict and eventually you would
learn they should just at your W equal
to zero and that would be fine so this
is just reducing the noise and the
target that we're trying to sort of if
you think of this as a supervised
learning problem we have an input X and
output Y the challenge in RL is that our
Y is changing if you make it that your
so your Y is not changing it's much
easier to fit and the second is whether
or not there's any benefit beyond
stability I think mostly not I
the this is also sort of reducing how
quickly you propagate information
because you're using a stale set of
weights to represent the value of the
state so you might miss estimate the
value of a state because you haven't
updated it with old employment with new
information we want to do or
approximately there's this complex
question which is is this specific to
deep neural networks or could use this
with linear value function approximate
or any value part you could use it with
any value function approximator yeah
this is not specific this is really just
about stability and that's that's true
for the experience replay to experience
replay is just going to propagate
information more effectively and this is
just gonna make it more stable so these
aren't sort of unique to using deep
neural network I think they were just
more worried about the stability with
these really complicated function
approximator z' yeah in the red yeah -
that always there for us great vision so
that
whether or not we ever update w - yes
we'd compare eaat eclis update w - as
well so in a fixed schedule say every 50
or you know every and episodes or every
n steps you update so like every and you
would set W minus 2w we know that this
is for creating your set and you're not
using the same kind of structure as
gradients that you're using great
yeah but a different function
subtracting the time value but we have a
project how is this supposed to like not
break greatly like all those assumptions
hold it says okay this does this really
work good terms of gradients that this
is not I mean the it's a great question
and these sort of q-learning are not
true gradient descent methods they're
they're approximations to such they
often do shockingly well given that some
of the more recent ones which Chapter
eleven has a nice discussion of this or
the G TDS or a gradient in temporal
difference learning are more true
gradient descent algorithms these are
really just approximations and exactly
this as nears point this has no
guarantees of convergence still this is
hopefully gonna help but so it be
practice to people as some cyclical
pattern and talked and they refresh
those waiting that's used to compute
radians you know in practices there's
some sort of cyclical pattern of how
often you update W - yes yeah there's
often particular patterns or hyper it's
a hyper parameter choice of how quickly
how frequently you update this and it
will trade off between propagating
information faster and possibly being
less stable so if you make you know if
if n here is one that you're back to
standard TD learning if n is infinity
that means you've never updated it so
there's a there's a smooth continuing
there we use there are better
initializations
than just like zero something like you
did you into account I guess like the
mean and variance we do this was W -
just to W or is there I think you did
initialization is about you know that
the impact of how we initialize w could
matter and is that how do we initialize
w - typically we - there's w - to be
exactly the same as w at the beginning
the choice of it will also affect
certainly the early performance great
questions let me keep going I want to
make sure we get to some of the
extensions as well so just to summarize
how dqn works the main two innovations
it did is it uses experience replay them
execute targets it stores the transition
and this replay buffer a replay memory
you sample random mini batches from deed
it's normally a sample in mini batch
instead of a single one example 10 or
whatever other parameter you do your
gradient descent given those you compute
q-learning using these old targets and
you optimize the mean squared error
between the queue network and the queue
learning targets use stochastic gradient
descent and something I did not mention
on here is that we're typically doing a
greedy exploration and so you need some
schedule here - for how to decay greedy
so they were not doing sophisticated
exploration in the original paper so
this is what it looks like you sort of
going you do multiple different
convolutions they have the images and
they do some fully connected layers and
then the output a queue value for each
action well let me just bring it up for
those of you who haven't seen it before
so the nice thing is what they so you're
about to see breakout which is an Atari
game and what they do is they show you
sort of the performance of what the
agent is doing so remember the agents
just learning from pixels here how to do
this so it was pretty extraordinary when
they showed this in about 2014 and the
beginning of its learning sort of this
policy you can see it's not making doing
the right thing very much and then over
time as it gets more episodes it's
starting to learn to make better
decisions about how to do it and one of
the interesting things about it is that
as you'd hope as it gets more and more
data it learns to make better decisions
but one of the things people like about
this a lot is that you can learn to
exploit the reward function
so in this big yrs out that if you
really just want me to maximize the
expected reward what the best thing for
me to do is to just kind of get a hole
through there and then as soon as I can
start to just that's around the top load
and so this is one of the things where
you know if you ask the agent to
maximize the reward a little learned the
right way to maximize the reward given
enough data and and so this was really
cool that sort of it could discover
things that may be or strategies that
people take a little while to learn when
they're first learning the game as well
so what they did this they then showed
some pretty amazing performance on a lot
of different games many games they could
do as well as humans now to be precise
here oh yeah
I'm just wondering why well--that's
planed it ball was like stirring around
a lot like it wasn't sure that some
movements like it moves around places
often like yeah
yeah so you might see I think I could
refrain to the fact that the paddle was
moving a lot as the agents trying to
learn like when we've that see that
users ago why would you jerk a lot from
the ages perspective particularly if
there's a cost to moving then it may
just be kind of babbling and doing
exploration just to see what works and
and it from our perspective that's
clearly sort of an inexperienced player
to do that that would be a strange thing
but from the agents perspective that's
completely reasonable it's not giving
positive or negative reward from that so
it can't distinguish between University
and stationary versus going left or
right if you put in a cost for movement
that could help there I don't remember
the complete network architecture and
whether or not there was a pooling layer
in there I think the problem there might
be inside their house they have to be
going from images all the way up but
they have the complete architecture
question so the nice thing that you can
see here is that they got sort of human
level performance on a number of
different Atari games there's about 50
games up here just to be clear here when
they say human level performance that
means asymptotically so after they have
trained their agent they say they're not
talking about how long it took them or
their agent to learn and as you guys
will find out for homework two it can be
a lot of experience a lot of time to
learn how to make do good performance
but nevertheless there are a lot of
cases where that might be reasonable in
terms of games and so they did variable
on some domains some domains they did
very poorly there's been a lot of
interest in these sort of games on the
bottom end of the tail which often known
as hard exploration games will probably
talk we'll talk a lot more about
exploration later on in the course so
what was critical so I like the lots of
really lovely things about this paper
and one of the really nice things is
that they did a nice ablation study and
for us to sort of understand what were
the important features and if you look
at these numbers I think it's clear that
the really important feature is replay
so this is their performance using a
linear network deeply networked seem to
not help so much
using that fixed queue fixed queue here
means you seem like a fixed target okay
that gets you like a little bit three
from ten you do
play it suddenly at 241 so throwing away
each data point what after you use it
once is not a very good thing to do you
want to reuse that data and then if you
combine replay and fixed queue you do
get an improvement over that but it's
really that you get this huge increase
at least and break out in some of the
other games by doing replay now in some
other ones you start to get a
significant improvement as soon as use a
more complicated function approximator
but in general replay is hugely
important and it just gives us a much
better way to use the data yeah yeah
just here on this table it seems like
you would want to use replay in fixed
queue with the linear model and then it
might be a mistake to be using a a deep
model here do you agree with that well
maybe good use like linear oh so I guess
I should be clear so this is all
everything on the next four we're all
deep so they don't have here linear plus
replay but you could certainly imagine
trying linear plus replay and it seems
like you might do very well here might
depend on which features you're using
there's some cool work over the last few
years looking also it whether you can
combine these two so we've done some
work using a Bayesian last layer using
like Bayesian linear regression which is
useful for uncertainty other people have
just done linear regression where the
idea is you use sort of a deep neural
network up to a certain point and then
you do kind of direct linear regression
to fit exactly what the weights are at
the final layer and so that can be much
more data efficient but you still have a
complicated representation all right so
since then there's been a huge number
amount of interest in this area so again
dating myself reinforcement learning
used to go and give a talk about
reinforcement learning I'm like forty
people would show up but most of them
you knew and and then I and then it
started really changing I think it was
maybe in 2016 when ICML was in New York
and like suddenly there were 400 people
in the room for reinforcement learning
talks and then this year at nurbs which
is one of the major machine learning
conferences it sold out in like eight
minutes so there were 8,000 people there
and there was a huge amount of interest
in deep learning and for the deep
learning workshop you sort of have a
2,000 person audit
so there's been a huge amount of
excitement based on this work which i
think really a huge credit to deep mind
and to the work of David silver and
others have been doing to sort of show
that this was possible some of the media
provements that we're gonna go through
really quickly here is double D queue
and prioritize replay and Julian dqn
there's been way way way more papers
than that but these are some of the
early really big improvements on top of
DQ n so double D QN is kind of like
double Q learning which we covered very
briefly at the end of a couple classes
ago and the thing that we discussed
there was the sort of maximization bias
is that the max of estimated state
action values can be a biased estimator
of the true max
and so we talked really briefly about
double Q learning so a double Q learning
the idea was that we're going to
maintain two different queue networks we
can select our action using like an e
greedy policy where we average between
those Q networks and then we'll observe
a reward an estate and we basically use
one of the Q's as the target for the
other so if you know with a 50%
probability we're going to update one
Network and we're going to do that by
using picking the action from the other
network this is to try to separate how
we pick our action versus our estimate
of the value of that action to deal with
this sort of maximization bias issue and
then with 50% other probability we
update q2 and we pick the next action
from the other network so this is a
pretty small change means you have four
you have to maintain two different
networks or two different sets of
weights and it can be pretty helpful so
if you extend this idea to DQ n you have
sort of our current Q Network W disliked
actions and this older one to evaluate
actions so you can put this in there to
do action selection and then you can
evaluate the value of it with your other
networks
other Network weeks so it's a fairly
small change it's very similar to what
we were doing already for the target
network network weights and it turns out
that it gives you a huge benefit in many
many cases for the Atari games so this
is something that's generally very
useful to do and gives users an
immediate significant boost in
performance so you know for the
equivalent of like a small amount of
coding that's one idea
and that sort of a direct lift up from
sort of you know double Q learning the
second thing is prioritize B play so
let's go back to the Mars rover example
I so in Mars rover we had this really
small domain we're talking about tabular
setting through just seven states and we
were talking about a policy that just
always took action a1 which turned out
to mostly go left so we had this
trajectory we started off in state s3 we
took action a1 we got a reward of zero
we went to s2 we stayed in s2 for one
round when we did a 1 and then
eventually went to s1 and then we
terminated so that was this and the
first visit Monte Carlo estimate of V
for every state was 1 1 1 0 0 0 0 and
the TP estimate with alpha equal 1 was
this and that was when we talked about
the fact that TV only uses each data
point once and it didn't propagate the
information back so the only update for
TD learning was when we reached state s1
we took action 1 we got a reward of 1
and then we terminated so we only
updated the value of state whoa so now
let's imagine that you get to do so you
now think about what your likes or
replay buffer would be in this case
you'd have something like this you have
s3 a1 0 s 2 s 2 a 1 0 s 2 s 2 a 1 0 s 1
s 1 a 1 1 terminate that's what your
replay buffer would look like so let's
say you get to choose to replay backups
to do so you have four possible replay
backups you can pick the same one twice
if you want to and I'm going to ask you
to pick to replay backups to do to
improve the value function
some way and I'd like you to think for a
second or talk to our neighbor about
which of the two you should pick and why
and which order you would do them in as
well and whether it makes any difference
maybe really it doesn't matter you just
pick any of these you're gonna get the
same value function no matter what you
do so are there two two updates that are
particularly good if so why and what
order would hopefully think about that
for a second first of all does it matter
so I'm gonna first ask you guys the
question vote if you think it matters
which ones you pick in terms of the
value function you get out that's right
so it absolutely matters which two you
pick in terms of the resulting value
function you will not get the same value
function no matter what you pick now
I'll ask for another Bodines will ask
for which one we should do first should
we update it should we do for first or
is the last one in our replay buffer
should we do three first should you two
first
okay
all right so threes have it - somebody
want to explain why yeah I'll see you
got a back propagate the information you
already know on state one to state two
yeah so what is right so if you pick
back up three so what's back up three it
is s 2 A 1 0 s 1 so if you do the back
up that's 0 plus gamma of V of s prime s
1 and this is 1 so that means now you're
going to get 2 back up and so now your B
of s 2 is going to be equal to 1 so you
get to back up that information so I I
wasn't extremely specific on what like
the right thing to do here is that but
the but my main thing is that I wanted
to emphasize that it makes a big
difference
and that it's going to matter in terms
order what's the next one we should do
should we do raise your hand if we
should do three again raise your hand if
we should do to raise your hand if we
should do one yep the ones have it it
someone explain why that's right yes so
if you wanted to get all the way to the
Monte Carlo estimate what you would want
to do here is you'd want to do s 3 a 1 0
s 2 which would allow your B of s 3 to
be updated to 1 and at this point your
value function will be exactly the same
as the Monte Carlo so it definitely
matters it matters the order in which
you did it do it if you had done s 3
a-10s to your s 3 wouldn't have changed
so ordering can make a big difference so
not only do we want to think about like
what was being brought up before but I
think then to say like what should we
put in our replay buffer not only do you
not think about what should be in a
replay buffer but also what order do we
sample them can make a big difference in
terms of convergence rates I and in
particular there's some really cool work
from a couple years ago looking at this
formally of like how what the ordering
matters so there is this paper back in
2016 that tried to look at what the
optimal order would be so imagine that
you had an Oracle that could exactly
compute now this is going to be
computationally intractable we're not
gonna be able to do this in general
imagine that Oracle could go through and
pick and figure out exactly what the
right order is then what they found out
in this case is that for this or a small
chain like example and you get this
exponential improvement in convergence
which is pretty awesome so what does
that mean the number of updates you need
to do until your value function
converges to the right thing it can be
exponentially smaller if you update
carefully and you could have an Oracle
tell you exactly what tupple to sample
which is super cool so you could be much
much better but you can't do that you're
not going to spend all this it's um it's
very computationally expensive or
impossible in some cases to figure out
exactly what that I that Oracle ordering
should be but it does illustrate that
would that we might want to be careful
about the order that we do it in so
their intuition for this was let's try
to prioritize a tuple for replay
according to its DQ n error so the DQ n
error in this case is just our TD
learning error so it's going to be the
difference between our current this is
basically our prediction error so this
is our prediction error almost our
prediction error I'll just call it TD
because it's not quite because we're
doing it max so this is like sort of our
predicted or - our current - say if you
have a really really big error then
we're gonna prioritize updating that
more and you update this quiet quantity
at every update you set it for new
tuples to be zero and one method they
have two different methods for trying to
do this sort of prioritization but one
method basically takes these priorities
raises them to some power alpha and then
normalizes and then that's the
probability of selecting that tupple so
you prioritize more things that are wait
so yeah there's I'm freezing the old
weights or the counter to propagating
back the information that's like if you
froze the old ways and an example we're
just going through after you only
propagated the one back once you
wouldn't be able to do it anymore
because your value would still be zero
it makes a great point which is if you
were fixing
your w- then if you were looking at our
case that we had before then you
wouldn't be able to continue propagating
that back because you wouldn't have
updated yet yeah that's exactly right so
there's going to be this tension between
when you fix things versus or
propagating information back i and it's
it's attention that one has to straight
figure out there's not necessarily
principled ways for exactly what the
right schedule is to do that but it's a
hyper parameter to do changing okay so
does ordering matter at all in that case
it still matters because we're still
going to be delayed and replay over the
weights will be changing during the time
period of which will be replaying over
that buffer so that buffer could be like
million and you might update your
weights like every fifty steps or
something like that so there's still
going to be a whole bunch of data points
in I in your replay buffer that it's
useful to think about now that your
weights have changed what ordering do
you want to go through those it's a
great question okay so what method is
this let me just just to clarify if we
said alpha equal to zero
what's the rule for selecting among
existing tuples so out so P is our sort
of basically our DQ n error if we set
alpha equal to zero you know that's
right yeah so so this sort of trades off
between uniform no prioritization to
completely picking the one that I'm like
if alphas infinity then that's gonna be
picking the one with the highest DQ
inner so it's a trade off it's a
stochastic alright so then they combine
this with sort of the reason I'm picking
these three order to do is they all sort
of layer on top of each other so
prioritize replay versus I think this is
part times replay plus DM double DQ n
versus just double D QN most the time
this is zero would be they're both the
same underneath means flat vanilla DQ
double D QN is better above means the
prioritize replay is better
most the time prioritize replay is
better and there's some hyper parameters
here to play with but most the time this
is useful and it's certainly useful to
think about you know where order might
matter all right we don't have very much
time left so I'm just gonna do short
through this just so you're aware of it
the best papers from ICML 2016 was duly
the idea is that if you want to make
decisions in the world there might be
some states that are better or worse and
they're just gonna have higher value or
lower value but that what you really
want to be able to do is figure out what
the right action is to do in a
particular state and so that what you
want to sort of understand is this
advantage function you want to know how
much better or worse taking a particular
action is versus following the current
policy but really like I don't care
about assuming the value of a state I
care about being able to understand
which of the actions has the better
value is overlooking this advantage
function so what they do to do this is
that in contrast to dqn where you output
all of the cues they're gonna separate
and they're gonna first estimate the
value of a state and they're gonna
estimate this advantage function which
is Q of s a 1 minus V of s Q of s a 2
minus V of S they're just gonna separate
it it's an architecture choice and
they're gonna recombine these for the Q
and then argue this is gonna help us
sort of focus on the signal that we care
about which is be enough to accurately
estimate which action is better or worse
there's interesting questions about
whether or not this is identifiable I
don't have enough time to go into these
today it's not identifiable I'm happy to
talk about all of that offline and I the
the reason this is important is they
just forces one to make some sort of
default assumptions about specifying the
advantage functions empirically it's
often super helpful
so again compared to double DQ n with
prioritized replay which we just saw
which was already better than W double
DQ n which is also better than DQ n this
again gives you another performance gain
substantial one and so basically these
are sort of three three different ones
that came up within the sort of two
years after DQ n that started making
some really big performance games
compared to just doing completely
vanilla our DQ n for homework two you're
going to be implementing DQ n not the
other ones that you're welcome to
implement some of the other ones it's
just good to be aware of those are some
sort of the major initial improvements
to getting substantially better
performance on Atari
um I'll leave these up we're almost out
of time feel free to look at the last
couple slides of this for some practical
tips that came from John Schulman John
Shulman was a PhD student at Berkeley
that is now one of the heads of opening
I just one thing that I will make sure
to highlight it can be super tempting to
try to start by like implementing key
learning directly on Atari I highly
encourage you to first go through sort
of the order of the assignment and like
do it the linear case make sure your cue
learning is totally working and before
you deploy on Atari even with the
smaller games like pong which we're
working on and it is enormous ly
time-consuming and so in terms of just
understanding and debugging it's way
better to make sure that you know your
cue learning method is working before
you wait 12 hours to see whether or not
oh it didn't learn anything on pong so
that there's a reason for why we sort of
build up the way we do in the assignment
just another practical to a few other
practical tips feel free to to look at
those and there won't meet more on
Thursday Thanks